a recent study found that more than 55
million Americans will use a sharing
economy service at least once this year
the most popular services in this
country or of course the ride-hailing
app uber and home rental Booker Airbnb
no where in the world is the sharing
economy more popular than in China last
year 600 million Chinese people used a
sharing service Ben Tracy in Beijing
shows us how the sharing economy has
taken off in China but has left some
asking if it's too much of a good thing
bikes are now big business in China the
country's two largest bike share
companies owe fo and mobike complete a
combined 50 million rides everyday
investors recently poured more than a
billion dollars into the companies which
explains the sea of bikes on the street
and the massive piles of pedals growing
in China's major cities the sharing
economy brings convenience this woman
said but this is too much like a friend
who doesn't quite know when to stop
China might be over sharing you can
share a basketball for 15 cents an hour
need to charge your phone there's a
power bank share for that and then came
the shared beds which many called
napping pods to make it sound slightly
less gross shortly after they opened
they were shut down for not meeting fire
code but the moment the sharing economy
seemingly jumped the shark here in China
is when an entrepreneur opened his
umbrella on a dark day and had what he
thought was a bright idea the umbrella
share launched in Shanghai turned out to
be all wet 300,000 umbrellas went
missing probably because people just
decided to keep them we might look at
some of these ideas in the US and say
that sounds kind of silly are they
perceived differently here I think what
is different here is there is just a lot
of adoption of new things people try
things all the time there's almost this
idea what's new and what's cool and
people do jump into them and in a
country of more than a billion people
it's a lot of jumping china sharing
economy jumped more than 75 percent in
size last year it's expected to grow
another 40
sent this year to more than 700 billion
dollars and could account for 20% of
China's GDP by 2025 the most successful
example is China's version of uber
called DD it is now the largest
ride-sharing company in China in just
one year it completed one point four
billion rides it took over six years to
reach the 1 billion mark we don't know
where this is going but we know where at
the beginning of something huge one
issue here seems to be things that are
labeled as part of the sharing economy
that really aren't the latest would be
shared refrigerators you use your phone
you scan a little code on it you open it
up and you decide what you want to eat
well in the u.s. we might call that a
vending machine Ben Tracy CBS News
Beijing very good that's pretty good
although there are some refrigerators
where people label everything that means
you really can't share fresh food in
there like they like the one over here
in our studio same idea